[Music]
Leopold perhaps go and read in the
library I want to see
Alicia she was my friend too you're not
scared of ghosts I talk to ghosts here
all the time do
you they say you're a
fake
no one touched me until the transis
ended Alysia Drake I believe it was you
who called to
me too many
Spirits this house is spilling with the
dead some Souls can't let go do we stop
Miss Reynolds no if someone wants to be
heard we are here
listening Spirits you scream and shout
and no one hears we do
now Alysia Drake Find Your Voice
it just got cold does anyone else feel a
chill is someone
there by yes she didn't touch the key I
swear she must have you can't all be
such fools this is wrong this is very
wrong who is there Alicia Drake
listening we are here
listening it is the Hallow time
we are close your spirit is close your
voice is
loud
Alysia Alysia Alysia I feel you are in
pain does it hurt please tell
me did someone hurt you yes no Farrow
let her finish no first let us meet a
secret Confederate in that
chimney Nicholas are you hurt I'm all
right ah
Nicholas the second assistant I am
pleased to meet you by your similar and
piercing green eyes I take you for the
first assistance half
brother magnetic
switch voila the talking typ right now a
fake Mrs SE your dedication to
housekeeping could be improved no one
had been in this room except you yet my
new friend left his footstep in the
fireplace the bright scratch at the
keyhole indicates a lock recently picked
Miss Oliver you must find a new subject
for your book M Drake I am sorry for
your loss but this Oracle is a
[Music]
fake
where's Baba did someone take him did
you I didn't touch
[Applause]
anything
M
thirsty so
thirsty
felia
hurt W leave
me I don't
want I don't want to die what is
happening Alicia showing me I see her on
the balcony not alone she didn't jump
murderer a you killed me you killed me
who show me who you killed me you killed
me you killed me who hurt you you killed
me you killed me show me you killed me
who Hur you what
happened
murder